This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Nearly a decade ago, I had this thought that at the end of the year, it would be nice to tell a few little stories. We call them mini stories. Many stories maybe don't rise a level of being a fully reported story, and often there's something silly or interesting that was on the producer's mind. Maybe it's an outtake from a reported episode. Maybe it's something completely new. Many stories were a way to have some fun at the end of the year, and for the staff to take a proper vacation. That was how it all started.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。大约十年前，我曾萌生过这样一个想法：如果在年底时，能讲几个短短的故事，那该多好。我们把它们叫做迷你故事。许多迷你故事或许还够不上被深度报道的级别，而且通常是制作人脑子里觉得有些荒诞或有趣的想法。也许它是某个报道过的单集里的未采用片段，也许它是个全新出炉的内容。迷你故事是年底时自娱自乐的一种方式，也是让全体员工能真正休个假的好机会。一切就是这样开始的。
But over the years, many stories have become a monster. Everyone started preparing really heavily for them. They started reporting them as full stories. And suddenly, many stories were not so many. So this year, I decided unilaterally to stop mini inflation and go back to the fundamentals. All the producers are going to join me in a Zoom room together and tell me stories that I have not heard before. I am not prepared. I don't know anything about what's going to be told to me.
但这些年来，迷你故事已经变成了一个怪兽。每个人都开始为它们投入极大的精力去做准备。他们开始像报道完整故事那样去筹备它们。突然之间，迷你故事一点也不“迷你”了。所以今年，我单方面决定制止这种迷你故事的通货膨胀，回归本质。所有的制作人都要和我一起加入一个 Zoom 会议室，给我讲一些我以前从没听过的故事。我毫无准备。对于他们要讲的内容，我一无所知。
So let's just jump in. And first up is producer Chris Perrupe. Chris, how you doing? Roman, it is the most wonderful time of the year. Many stories. Let's do this. I like the attitude. What do you have for us?
那我们直接开始吧。首先登场的是制作人克里斯·佩鲁佩（Chris Perrupe）。克里斯，最近怎么样？罗曼，这是全年中最美好的时光。迷你故事时间。我们开始吧。我喜欢这个态度。你给我们带来了什么？
So, Roman, I want to call back to a story we did a little bit earlier this year. It's a story that I reported about the Great American Pyramid. A new pyramid is being built, not to glorify death, but is a monument. that will celebrate life and man's indomitable spirit to create. Feel the power of the Great American Pyramid. So did you just want an excuse to play that clip again? Yeah, pretty much. That's the whole story.
罗曼，我想回顾一下我们今年早些时候做过的一个故事。那是我报道关于伟大美国金字塔（Great American Pyramid）的故事。一座正在建造的新金字塔，不是为了颂扬死亡，而是一座纪念碑，它将歌颂生命以及人类不屈不挠的创造精神。感受伟大美国金字塔的力量吧。所以你只是想找个借口再播一次那个音频片段吗？对，差不多就是这样。这就是全部的故事。
That's all I got. No, I have more pyramid stuff. So, Roman, we did this story about the Great American Pyramid in Memphis, Tennessee. Of course, today, the Great American Pyramid is a Bass Pro shop. That's right. And when it opened in 1991, you know, it was supposed to be the tallest pyramid in the United States. But, Roman, did you know, shortly after the construction of the Great American Pyramid, there was an even bigger American pyramid. How much bigger are we talking?
我就这点东西。不，我还有更多关于金字塔的内容。罗曼，我们之前做过田纳西州孟菲斯市伟大美国金字塔的故事。当然，如今的伟大美国金字塔是一家巴斯普罗户外专卖店（Bass Pro Shops）。没错。当它在 1991 年开业时，你知道的，它本应是美国最高的金字塔。但是，罗曼，你知道吗，就在伟大美国金字塔建成后不久，出现了一座更大的美国金字塔。我们说的是大多少？
So the Great American Pyramid was 32 stories high. I was there for the story. I was inside the building. It really feels cavernous when you're in there. Like, it's really big. And then in 1993, two years after the pyramid. opened, another pyramid opened in Las Vegas, Nevada, and it was 350 feet tall. So that was a whopping 29 feet taller than the Great American pyramid. Oh, that's so mean. That
所以伟大美国金字塔有 32 层楼高。我当时为了做报道去过那里。我进到了建筑物内部。当你身处其中时，真的会感觉里面像洞穴一样空旷。真的非常大。然后到了 1993 年，也就是金字塔开业两年后，内华达州拉斯维加斯又开业了一座金字塔，它有 350 英尺高。所以它比伟大美国金字塔足足高了 29 英尺。哦，这也太刻薄了。那
reminds me of the sort of skyscraper wars in the early 20th century, just like just slightly taller. Yeah, it feels petty, right? It feels extremely deliberate. And I assume it was on purpose. I asked around, I talked to people, nobody could confirm that for me, but you have to assume, right? Yeah, yeah. So in your story, if I remember correctly, the city of Memphis had a problem finding a use for the pyramid after it sort of failed as a venue. It's now this woodsy mall that has a bass pro shop in it. So what are they doing with this Las Vegas pyramid? So the Vegas pyramid, it has had one use the whole time. It is home to the Luxor Casino. Oh, that's right. Much like the Memphis pyramid, it also has a hotel inside. And it has lots of
让我想起 20 世纪初的摩天大楼大战，就是那种只比别人高一点点的竞争。对，感觉很小肚鸡肠，对吧？感觉极其故意。我猜这是故意的。我到处打听，跟人们聊过，没人能向我证实这一点，但你肯定会这么想，对吧？对，对。所以在你的故事里，如果我没记错的话，孟菲斯市在金字塔作为活动场馆失败后，曾为如何利用它而头疼。它现在成了里面有家巴斯普罗户外专卖店的林地风格购物中心。那么他们对拉斯维加斯的这座金字塔是怎么处理的呢？拉斯维加斯的金字塔，这么多年来只有一个用途。它是卢克索赌场（Luxor Casino）的所在地。哦，对了。和孟菲斯金字塔很像，它的内部也有一家酒店。而且它有许多
attractions for tourists. There's this big room with lots of old Titanic stuff in it. It's a really interesting building. And actually, it has one very unique pyramid feature that I'd like to draw your attention to. There are no elevators inside. We actually have inclinators that go up the side of the building at 39 degrees. So this is Billy Padavis. He's the facilities director at the Luxor pyramid. It's almost like a roller coaster as you're going up the steep incline before the drop. Rides on rail and wheels, it pulls you up the side. That is so cool. I love going up an incline plane.
面向游客的景点。这里有一个大房间，里面摆着许多关于泰坦尼克号的老物件。这是一栋非常有趣的建筑。事实上，它有一个非常独特的金字塔特色，我想提请你注意。里面没有电梯。我们实际上有倾斜电梯（inclinators），沿着建筑物侧面以 39 度角向上运行。这位是比利·帕达维斯（Billy Padavis）。他是卢克索金字塔的设施主管。在下落之前，当你沿着陡峭的斜坡向上时，感觉几乎就像坐过山车一样。它靠轨道和车轮运行，把你拉上侧面。太酷了。我喜欢坐斜面电梯。
I love an inclinator. That was something that came up in the Great Pyramid episode. I love the idea of it. That's right. They actually never built theirs. They just built an elevator right in the center. So this one actually has inclinators on the side. But, Roman, there is one other feature of this pyramid that is very famous.
我喜欢倾斜电梯。这在《大金字塔》那一集里也提到过。我非常喜欢这个概念。没错。他们实际上从未建造过他们自己的斜面电梯。他们只是在正中心建了一部普通的电梯。所以这座金字塔的侧面确实有倾斜电梯。但是，罗曼，这座金字塔还有一个非常著名的特色。
It is very striking. So at the top of the Luxor pyramid, there is this very powerful light that beams up into the sky every night. I have shared a photo with you if you want to take a look at it. This is the beam. That is amazing looking. That is like a little scary, like an ominous black pyramid with a light coming out of it. It's kind of like Stargate, that movie Stargate. Does that predate you, Stargate? No, no, I've seen Stargate. I mean, to me, it reminds me of the opening credits of ancient aliens. Like, it's just kind of this ridiculous looking. Like, yeah, it is a black pyramid with a beam shooting straight up to like a mother ship or something. Like, that's what it
它非常引人注目。在卢克索金字塔的顶端，有一束非常强劲的光束，每天晚上都会射向夜空。如果你想看的话，我跟你分享了一张照片。这就是那束光。看起来太惊艳了。看起来有点吓人，就像一座会发光的险恶黑色金字塔。有点像《星际之门》，那部电影《星际之门》。《星际之门》比你年轻的时候还要早吗？不，不，我看过《星际之门》。我的意思是，对我来说，它让我想起了《远古外星人》的片头。就感觉它看起来太荒谬了。就像，是的，它是一座黑色的金字塔，有一束光直射向某种母舰之类的东西。听起来就是
looks like. And the Luxor sky beam, it has become this fixture of the Vegas skyline because it's really hard to miss, obviously. So at full power, the beam is said to have the same luminosity as 42 billion candles being lit at the same time. And it is so powerful. Apparently, airline pilots can see the Luxor beam from California. And actually, a couple years ago, I drove into Las Vegas for a story. I was coming over this hill and then suddenly you just see the beam. That's like the first thing you see that indicates like, oh, yeah, like Vegas. Vegas is over there. We're getting really close to Vegas. It's like this incredible tool for navigation. So how does a beam like that work? Like is it just one big light bulb? Is there lots
那个样子的。卢克索的天空之光已经成为了拉斯维加斯天际线的一个固定标志，因为显然它太显眼了，很难忽视。所以在全功率下，据说这束光的亮度相当于同时点亮 420 亿支蜡烛。而且它非常强大。显然，从加利福尼亚州的飞机飞行员都能看到卢克索的光束。事实上，几年前我为了做一个报道开车去拉斯维加斯。我正翻过这座山丘，然后突然间你就看到了那束光。那是你看到的第一个迹象，表明“哦，对啊，拉斯维加斯就在那儿。我们离拉斯维加斯真的很近了。”它就像是一个不可思议的导航工具。那么这样的光束是如何运作的呢？它只是一颗超大的灯泡吗？里面有很多
of light bulbs? I can't sort of fathom how you get something so bright and so clear. Right. So you're correct. It is a series of very bright light bulbs that are all using xenon gas. It started out as spotlights that uses a super bright light bulb. It's a sun tracker. You know, when it gets dark outside, the light comes on. When it gets bright, it turns off. It's certainly very Las Vegas to have like a bright light that turns on every single night, whether you want it or not. You know what you mean? But it's it's so bright that you can see it from California, you said. And is that distracting? Is it, is it dangerous if you're like flying a plane or something like that? I mean, that's a great question. And as best I can tell, there have been no incidents with airline pilots, helicopters, anything like that. But there is an issue that comes with operating a light of this size. It attracts the natural world. Just like when you turn on your light at home, that moth always goes towards the light. When we turn the beam on, there's moths up there.
灯泡吗？我有点无法想象怎么能弄出这么亮、这么清晰的东西。对的。所以你说得对。它是一系列非常明亮的灯泡，全部使用了氙气。它最初是作为使用超亮灯泡的探照灯开始的。它是一个太阳追踪器。你知道的，当外面天黑时，灯就会亮起。当外面变亮时，它就会熄灭。这种无论你愿不愿意、每天晚上都会亮起强光的做法，确实非常“拉斯维加斯”。你知道我的意思吗？但这光太亮了，以至于你从加利福尼亚都能看到，你刚才这么说的。这会让人分心吗？如果你在开飞机或类似的东西，这会有危险吗？我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。据我所知，还没有发生过与飞机飞行员、直升机或类似情况相关的事故。但运营这种规模的灯光确实带来了一个问题。它会吸引自然界的生物。就像你在家里开灯时，飞蛾总是会扑向光源一样。当我们打开光束时，上面会有飞蛾。
And then, you know, with moths, they brings predators. Bats come in and they eat. And there is an ecosystem up there. So you get insects, you get bats, you get owls. You get all kinds of birds that are drawn in by this thing. And Billy says that normally it's fine. Like they circle around the lights. Then the birds and the insects disperse when the light goes off.
然后呢，你知道的，有了飞蛾，就会引来捕食者。蝙蝠会飞来觅食。上面存在着一个生态系统。所以你会看到昆虫、蝙蝠、猫头鹰。各种各样的鸟类都被这个东西吸引过来。比利说，通常情况下这没什么问题。它们在灯光周围盘旋。然后当灯光熄灭时，鸟类和昆虫就会散去。
And it's interesting because I first became aware of the Luxor beam because of a news story in 2019 about a very serious bug problem that came to the Las Vegas strip. Oh, no. So, Robin, I'm actually going to ask you to watch the video for a second and just give a reaction to what you're saying on screen. In Sin City, it's the insect invasion putting on a show. No one can escape. A 24-7 onslaught of grasshoppers. For many, the first impression felt downright biblical. A migrating horde of bugs so big, you could even see them from space.
很有意思的是，我最初注意到卢克索的光束，是因为 2019 年的一则新闻报道，当时拉斯维加斯大道遭遇了非常严重的虫灾。哦，不。所以，罗曼，我实际上想请你看一会儿视频，并对屏幕上看到的内容做一下反应。在罪恶之城，这是一场上演的昆虫入侵大戏。无人能够逃脱。蝗虫大军 7 天 24 小时疯狂来袭。对许多人来说，第一印象简直就像是圣经里的灾难。迁徙中的虫群大天大，你甚至能从太空中看到它们。
Oh, my God. Yeah, it just covered like every surface of the Vegas strip for a couple of weeks. And this was 2019. So in 2019, Nevada had this very rainy winter and then it had this very mild spring. And that is the exact cocktail for a productive breeding season for the pallid-winged grasshopper. And it is notable that these grasshoppers are drawn to artificial lights. What we saw was that the urban lights in Las Vegas, sort of act as an attractant on the landscape,
哦，天哪。对，它在短短几周内几乎覆盖了拉斯维加斯的每一个表面。这是 2019 年的事。所以在 2019 年，内华达州经历了一个多雨的冬天，接着又迎来了非常温和的春天。这正是浅翅蝗（pallid-winged grasshopper）繁衍盛季的完美组合。值得一提的是，这些蝗虫会被人造光吸引。我们看到的是，拉斯维加斯的城市灯光在景观中起到了引诱剂的作用，
drawing these insects in to what is otherwise very poor habitat, right? Parking lots in the strip of Vegas is not an interesting or attractive place for a grasshopper to be, but this light is drawing them in. So this is Dr. Elskine-Lins. She's an insect biologist who studied this giant swarm of grasshoppers. And using radar data, she says it's clear the grasshoppers were moving towards Vegas at night when all these artificial lights were on, right? So at its peak, according to Dr. Tylans, there were about 45 million grasshoppers on the Vegas strip.
将这些昆虫吸引到原本非常贫瘠的栖息地，对吧？停车场和拉斯维加斯大道对蝗虫来说并不是一个有趣或有吸引力的地方，但这束光把它们吸引了过来。这位是厄斯金-林斯博士（Dr. Elskine-Lins）。她是一位昆虫生物学家，曾研究过这群巨大的蝗虫。根据雷达数据，她表示很明显，这些蝗虫是在夜晚所有这些人工照明开启时向拉斯维加斯移动的，对吧？因此，据泰兰斯博士（Dr. Tylans）称，在巅峰时期，拉斯维加斯大道上大约有 4500 万只蝗虫。
I can't even imagine that number. It is a tremendous number. It's more grasshoppers than that Las Vegas gets human visitors over the course of a year. So Vegas was this magnet for grasshoppers. And in all this news coverage, there is footage of these grasshoppers swirling around in the sky beam. And Billy says, okay, yes, there were a ton of bugs. There were so many bugs. Nobody could walk around without being swarmed by bugs.
我简直无法想象那个数字。这是一个庞大的数字。这比拉斯维加斯一年内接待的人类游客数量还要多。所以拉斯维加斯成了蝗虫的磁铁。在所有的这些新闻报道中，都有这些蝗虫在天空光束周围盘旋的镜头。比利说，好吧，是的，确实有很多虫子。有太多的虫子了。没有人能在不被虫群包围的情况下四处走动。
But this was not specifically the beam's fault, right? Las Vegas has lots of artificial lights. And Dr. Tylen's, she says, yes, we cannot single out the sky beam here. So is this still a problem? Was it just that season? No, Las Vegas is not still overwhelmed by grasshoppers. This was a fairly short phenomenon. So these grasshoppers don't live super long.
但这并不是这束光专门的错，对吧？拉斯维加斯有大量的人造灯光。泰兰斯博士说，是的，我们不能单把这里的这束天空之光挑出来说事。所以这仍然是个问题吗？这只是那个季节的现象吗？不，拉斯维加斯现在并没有被蝗虫淹没。这只是一个相当短暂的现象。所以这些蝗虫的寿命并不长。
Most of them died off pretty fast. So the workers in Las Vegas had to clean up these giant piles of dead grasshoppers. But after seeing all this footage, like, it is hard for me not to think about the giant swarms of grasshoppers when I think about the sky beam and the Luxor pyramid, right? It was not their fault, but it is hard to get that image out of my head. Yeah, it is a haunting image. Well, thank you so much, Chris. This is fantastic. So are you going to give us, like, pyramid stories like all the time now?
它们大部分都很快死掉了。所以拉斯维加斯的工作人员不得不清理这些堆积如山的死蝗虫。但在看过所有这些镜头之后，当我想起天空之光和卢克索金字塔时，我很难不去想那些巨大的蝗虫群，对吧？这不是它们的错，但你很难把这个画面从脑子里赶走。对，这真是一个挥之不去的画面。好的，非常感谢你，克里斯。这太棒了。那么你现在是打算一直给我们讲金字塔的故事吗？
You're the pyramid correspondent? I guess I could do the Transamerica pyramid next. Absolutely. That's what's next. That's what I want. I guess so. So I should note, that is actually the tallest pyramid at America. I think it's the Luxor is by volume, the biggest pyramid, Transamerica Tallis.
你成金字塔记者了？我想我接下来可以讲讲泛美金字塔（Transamerica Pyramid）。绝对的。接下来就要讲这个。这正是我想要的。我想是的。所以我要指出的是，那其实是美国最高的金字塔。我认为就体积而言，卢克索是最大的金字塔，泛美则是最高的。
I don't know. You can send me to Egypt? Maybe that's the next step in all of this. We'll work on it. Thank you, Chris. Thanks, Roman. Up next, waiting patiently in our Zoom room. Actually, probably not waiting all that patiently, honestly.
我不知道。你可以把我派去埃及吗？也许那是所有这一切的下一步。我们会努力的。谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗曼。接下来，在我们的 Zoom 会议室里耐心等待的。老实说，其实可能没有那么有耐心。
She was the one complaining the most about having to sit on the rest of the Zoom with the rest of us is Vivian. What do you have for us? Roman, you asked us to keep it simple. so I am leaning out this year and I am just going to share a website that I've been fascinated with for years now, I think. So, Roman, can you do me a favor?
她就是那个抱怨最多、不得不和我们其他人一起留在 Zoom 里的人，维维安（Vivian）。你给我们带来了什么？罗曼，你让我们保持简单。所以我今年精简了许多，我打算分享一个让我着迷了好几年的网站。所以，罗曼，你能帮我个忙吗？
Go to your browser and type in G-A-I-L.com. G-A-I-L.com. Okay. And then what do you see? It says, hello and welcome to gale.comfack. This is a very simple text-based website.
打开你的浏览器，输入 G-A-I-L.com。G-A-I-L.com。好的。然后你看到了什么？上面写着：“你好，欢迎来到 gale.com 事实页面。”这是一个非常简单的纯文本网站。
It's a gray background, black type, and it has a few questions and answers. Yes. And so the whole website is maybe a page long. There's like nine questions and answers. And the first question reads, question, why isn't there any content here? Can't you at least throw up a picture of your cat for the internet to check out? And the answer is, sorry, I have a cat, but she's pretty unexciting by internet standards. As for why there is very little content here, we wanted to keep the server's attack surface as small as possible to keep it safe. Intriguing. So what are we looking at here? So although there is very little content on gale.com, this web page actually gets a ton of traffic. And that's because gale.com is a really common typo for gmail.com. Oh, that's so funny.
灰色的背景，黑色的字体，上面有几个问题和答案。对。所以整个网站可能只有一页长。大概有九个问题和答案。第一个问题是：“问题：这里为什么没有任何内容？难道你不能至少放张你的猫的照片让互联网网友来看看吗？”答案是：“对不起，我有一只猫，但按照互联网的标准，它相当平庸。至于为什么这里内容很少，我们希望将服务器的攻击面保持得尽可能小，以保证其安全性。”很有意思。那么我们在这里看到的是什么？尽管 gale.com 上的内容很少，但这个网页实际上获得了大量的流量。这是因为 gale.com 是 gmail.com 一个非常常见的拼写错误。哦，太有趣了。
That totally checks out. That totally seems like an internet thing. Yeah, exactly. So according to the gale.com fact page, in the year 2020, it received a total of 5 million. 950,012 hits, which was an average of about 16,257 hits per day. So it's a pretty steady flow of people, you know, missing the M in Gmail. And I was curious. So I checked the stats for our website, 99PI.org, which you plug at the end of every single episode. And gale.com gets about three times as much traffic as us and much of that by accident too. Okay, so who actually owns gale.com? I mean, Gail does. Oh, it's as simple as that.
这完全说得通。这完全感觉像是个互联网才会有的梗。对，完全如此。所以根据 gale.com 事实页面的数据，在 2020 年，它总共获得了 5,950,012 次点击，平均每天大约有 16,257 次点击。所以这是一个相当稳定的人流量，你知道的，都是漏掉了 Gmail 中的字母 m 的人。而且我很好奇。所以我查了我们网站的统计数据，也就是 99PI.org，你会在每一集的结尾宣传这个网址。而 gale.com 的流量大约是我们网站的三倍，而且其中很大一部分也是偶然访问的。好吧，那 gale.com 实际上是谁的？我是说，是盖尔（Gail）的。哦，就这么简单。
So who's Gail? I honestly don't know much about her, from what I could tell. Gail is a pretty private person. I haven't been able to find any interviews with her, and I've actually been trying to get in touch with her for about four years now, so I feel like I could safely say she's not interested in speaking with me. But according to the fact page, Gail received the domain name as a birthday present from her husband,
那盖尔是谁？说实话，我对他/她了解不多，从我所能了解到的来看。盖尔是一个非常注重隐私的人。我一直没能找到任何对她的采访，事实上我大约四年前就开始尝试联系她了，所以我觉得我可以肯定地说她对跟我说话不感兴趣。但根据事实页面，盖尔是在 1996 年从她丈夫那里收到这个域名作为生日礼物的，
back in 1996, which was actually about eight years before Gmail even existed. And fun fact, her husband who gifted her the domain, his name is Kevin, and he is the owner of Kevin.org, which redirects you to his LinkedIn profile. He was a man ahead of his time. Oh, yeah, Kevin was living in the year 2004. So according to Gail's fact page to you, her email provider rejects around 1.2 million misaddressed emails to Gail.com a week. Whoa. So that's a whole other level of server load. In addition to the six million visits, they get all this email that is not meant for them. That is crazy. I mean, you would think that with all these accidental visits every year to gale.com, it would be kind of a valuable property. Like you could put up more than just a fact page, you know, like or even that Google itself would want to buy it just to avoid any of this confusion. Yeah, yeah. I don't know if Google has ever attempted to buy gale.com. But it does already own. a bunch of misspelled versions of Google.com.
这实际上比 Gmail 诞生还要早大约八年。还有一个有趣的事实，送给她这个域名的丈夫，他的名字叫凯文（Kevin），他是 Kevin.org 的所有者，这个网址会把你重定向到他的领英（LinkedIn）个人主页。他是一个走在时代前面的人。哦，对，凯文生活在 2004 年。所以根据盖尔的事实页面，她的电子邮件服务提供商每周会拒收大约 120 万封地址拼写错误的发送给 Gail.com 的电子邮件。哇。所以这又是另一种级别的服务器负载了。除了六百万次的访问量之外，他们还收到了所有这些并非发给他们的电子邮件。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，你会认为每年有这么多对 gale.com 的意外访问，这应该算是一笔很有价值的资产。比如你可以放上去的不仅仅是一个事实页面，你知道的，甚至连谷歌自己都想买下它，只是为了避免所有这些混乱。对，对。我不知道谷歌是否曾试图购买 gale.com。但它确实已经拥有
That makes sense. Like G-O-G-O-G-G-O, yeah. That's exactly correct. Yes. They do own Google.com. They also own Gugel.com. Google with three O's. And then my personal favorite is gulge.com.
了一堆 Google.com 拼写错误的版本。
So if you type any of those into your web browser, it'll actually take you to Google. A lot of companies, like larger companies, will buy the common misspellings of their websites to prevent people from, like, doing this thing called typo squatting. Have you ever heard of that, Roman? I haven't heard of it, but I can kind of get it through context. Could you describe it a little bit more? Yeah, yeah. So it's like when a bad actor purposefully registers a similar, like a misspelling of a domain name to either like trick people and visiting their site.
这说得通。比如 G-O-G-O-G-G-O，对。完全正确。是的。他们确实拥有 Google.com。他们还拥有 Gugel.com。带有三个 O 的 Google。然后我个人最喜欢的是 gulge.com。
They use it for fishing schemes too or they'll try to sell it back to the company for a profit. Yeah, which is clearly not what Gail is doing. She predates all of those stuff. Gail seems just perfectly content, chilling on the domain name. She says pretty adamantly in the fact page if you read it. You know, she's like, yes, I know that I can monetize this, but no, I am not interested. So thank you very much. That's awesome. Longlivegail.com.
所以如果你在网络浏览器中输入任何这些网址，它实际上都会把你带到谷歌。许多公司，尤其是大公司，会购买他们网站的常见拼写错误版本，以防止人们进行被称为“域名抢注”的事情。罗曼，你听说过这个词吗？我没听说过，但我可以从语境中大致猜出来。你能再多描述一下吗？对，对。所以这就像是不法分子故意注册一个相似的域名，比如域名拼写错误，来欺骗人们访问他们的网站。
I'm a big fan of Gail without knowing who she is personally. This is a great story, Viv, and you kept to the many parameters very, very nicely. So thank you so much. I did as little work as possible, yes. But before I go, I did want to leave you with my second favorite example of a mistyped website. So, Roman, you know the site, githob.com, right? Yes, yes. It's sort of this website for checking in and storing coding projects and stuff like that, right? Yeah, yeah. Nobody really knows what it is. So it's spelled g-I-t-h-U-B.com. But can you do me another favor? Go back to your browser and type in g-U-T-H-I-B.com. So just invert the U and the I in GitHub.
他们也将其用于网络钓鱼骗局，或者他们会试图以利润把域名卖回给公司。是的，这显然不是盖尔在做的事。她比所有这些东西出现的时间都早。盖尔似乎对在这个域面上闲晃感到非常满足。如果你读了事实页面，她在上面说得很坚决。你知道，她就像是：“是的，我知道我可以把这个变现，但不了，我不感兴趣。所以非常感谢。”这太棒了。长命百岁吧，gail.com。
Guthip. Oh, this is a big four words that says, you spelled it wrong. Period. Yes. Awesome. That's so great. Well, thank you so much of this story, Vivian. I really had fun. Thank you, Roman.
在不认识她本人的情况下，我是盖尔的超级粉丝。这是一个很棒的故事，维维安，你把迷你故事的规则遵守得非常好。非常感谢你。我可是尽最大努力少干了点活，对吧。但在我离开之前，我还想留给你我第二喜欢的拼写错误网站的例子。所以，罗曼，你知道 githob.com 这个网站吧？对，对。这基本上是一个用于检入和存储编程项目之类的网站，对吧？对，对。其实没人真正知道它是什么。所以它是这样拼写的：g-I-t-h-U-B.com。但你能帮我另一个忙吗？回到你的浏览器，输入 g-U-T-H-I-B.com。也就是把 GitHub 中的 U 和 I 颠倒过来。
Okay, we're going to take a quick break here, and we'll be right back with another mini-story. Okay, we are back, and in the hot seat now is producer Jason. Jason DeLeon. Hey, Jason. Hey, Jason. Hey, there, Roman Mars. So we are wrapping up 2025 here. And one of the highlights for me, at least, was the conclave. Do you remember the conclave? Not like the movie conclave, but you mean like the real conclave. I mean the spectacle of the conclave. I mean the Catholic Church conclave. Where we got the Chicago Pope. Yes, yeah, it's a Chicago Pope. Did that rock your world, Roman? I know you're a Chicago guy. Well, I thought it was delightful that he was a Chicago Pope. Because like, when you know who the Pope's favorite, you're a Chicago Pope, you know who the Pope's favorite. baseball team is. Like, I think you're entering a more, like, different world. It's so true. Like, for me, I'm a big, like, I'm a hat guy and seeing the Pope rock a white socks hat. I was like, is this dude part of NWA? Like, what is going on? That's awesome. So, anyway, I bring this up
Guthip。哦，这里有四个显眼的大字写着：“你拼写错了。句号。”太棒了。太好了。好吧，非常感谢维维安带来的这个故事。我真的觉得很有趣。谢谢你，罗曼。
because one of the first actions the Pope took actually really hit home for me, specifically. So I live in Rhode Island, and Pope Leo declared the first miracle of his papacy right here in my home state. Okay. I did not hear about this. So tell me about the miracle of Rhode Island. Yeah. So this miracle, it took place in Pawtucket, which is like a small city right on the border with Providence. And the story goes that on the night of January 14th, 2007, a baby boy was born with a faint pulse. So the medical team worked on him for like over an hour and they just didn't have any signs of improvement. And pretty soon, they couldn't find a heartbeat at all. So the attending doctor recited a prayer, basically this final plea to a 19th century
好了，我们在这里稍作休息，马上回来分享另一个迷你故事。好的，我们回来了，现在坐在风口浪尖上的是制作人杰森（Jason）。杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）。嘿，杰森。嘿，杰森。嘿，罗曼·马尔斯。我们在做 2025 年的收尾工作。对我来说，至少亮点之一就是教皇选举（conclave）。你还记得教皇选举吗？不是像电影《教皇选举》那样，你是说真正的教皇选举。我是指教皇选举的壮观场面。我是指天主教会的教皇选举。我们选出了一个芝加哥教皇。是的，对，是个芝加哥教皇。这震撼了你的世界吗，罗曼？我知道你是芝加哥人。嗯，我觉得他是芝加哥教皇这事儿太逗了。因为就像，当你知道了教皇最喜爱的——你是个芝加哥教皇，你就知道教皇最喜爱的是哪支棒球队。我觉得你这是进入了一个更加、完全不同的世界。确实如此。就我而言，我是一个非常喜欢戴帽子的人，看到教皇戴着一顶白袜队（White Sox）的帽子。当时我想：这家伙是 NWA（说唱组合）的成员吗？这到底是怎么回事？太棒了。总之，我提起这个
Spanish priest from his hometown. And right after the doctor said this prayer, the boy's heartbeat returned. His breathing was normal. And miraculously, he grew up without complications. Oh, wow. Well, that's such a scary moment, of course. I don't know if I would necessarily qualify this as a miracle. I don't know if I want to weigh in on sort of divine intervention, but I'm really happy
是因为教皇采取的第一批行动之一实际上深深触动了我，特别是对我而言。我住在罗德岛州，教皇利奥（Pope Leo）就在我的家乡宣布了他的教皇任期内的第一个神迹。好的。我没听说过这事儿。所以跟我讲讲罗德岛的神迹吧。好的。这个神迹发生在波塔基特（Pawtucket），那是一个紧邻普罗维登斯边界的小城市。故事是这样的，2007 年 1 月 14 日深夜，一个男婴出生时只有微弱的脉搏。所以医疗团队抢救了他一个多小时，但他的病情没有任何好转的迹象。很快，他们连心跳都完全找不到了。于是，主治医生开始念诵祈祷文，这基本上是对他家乡的一位 19 世纪西班牙神父最后的恳求。就在医生念完这段祈祷文后，男孩的心跳恢复了。他的呼吸正常了。奇迹般的是，他健康长大了，没有任何并发症。哦，哇。这当然是个极其吓人的时刻。我不知道我是否一定会把这称为神迹。我不知道我是否想对某种神圣干预发表意见，但我真的很高兴
it turned out this way. Yes, likewise. Look, I don't want to particularly get into the miracle, not miracle of this all, but the reason I'm bringing this to the table is because I just find interesting that this happened back in 2007, like 19 years ago. So, so wait, the incident happened in 2007, but Pope Leo declared it a miracle like this year. He declared it a miracle in June of this year. Wow. Okay, so why the time gap? What was going on there? So, yeah, I called up a priest to talk about this. His name is Father Dorian Llewellyn. He's a theologian at Loyola Marymount University in Los Angeles.
事情是这样结局的。是的，彼此彼此。听着，我并不是特别想卷入这一切是不是神迹的讨论中，我把这个带到桌面上来的原因只是觉得很有趣，这发生在 2007 年，也就是 19 年前。所以，等等，这起事件发生在 2007 年，但教皇利奥在今年才宣布这是一个神迹？他在今年 6 月宣布这是一个神迹。哇。好吧，那为什么中间有这么长的时间差？那里面发生了什么？所以，是的，我打电话给一位神父来聊聊这件事。他的名字叫多利安·勒温神父（Father Dorian Llewellyn）。他是洛杉矶洛约拉马利蒙特大学（Loyola Marymount University）的神学家。
And Father Dorian told me that in order to declare a miracle in the Catholic Church, you have to go through a pretty elaborate process. It's a bureaucratic, necessarily bureaucratic process. And I have to tell you a little secret, which is that Vatican bureaucracy is not the most efficient in the world. I kind of gathered that from the Conclave movie, actually. So how does this process work? Like, how does the Catholic Church define a miracle? So I should say off the top here that I'm going to focus on medical miracles kind of specifically
多利安神父告诉我，要在天主教会宣布一个神迹，你必须经历一个相当复杂的程序。这是一个官僚化的、且必须官僚化的程序。我必须告诉你一个小秘密，那就是梵蒂冈的官僚机构并不是世界上最高效的。其实我从《教皇选举》那部电影里大致也看出来了。那这个程序是如何运作的呢？天主教会是如何定义神迹的？我首先应该说明的是，我将主要关注医疗神迹，
because me and Father Dorian mostly talked about that. And so, yeah, these medical miracles, they have to check three boxes. The first, the healing must directly follow a prayer to a holy person. The second, the healing must take place in ways that the best. informed scientific knowledge cannot account for. And the third is that the healing must be lasting. Interesting. So how is it determined whether all those three criteria happened in the Rhode Island miracle?
因为我和多利安神父大部分时间都在谈论这个。所以，是的，这些医疗神迹必须符合三个条件。第一，治愈必须直接发生在向某位圣人祈祷之后。第二，治愈的发生方式是拥有最佳科学知识的专家也无法解释的。第三，治愈必须是持久的。有趣。那么，如何确定罗德岛的神迹是否符合这三个标准呢？
Yeah. So in the case of the Rhode Island miracle, the Diocese of Providence, they caught wind of this story. And the first thing they do is they get a group of people together to investigate it. So you have to look at it almost like a government commission. So you can have to meet with the people. You have to take notes. You have to take into account medical records. It's forensic in that way.
对。所以在罗德岛神迹的案例中，普罗维登斯教区听到了这个故事的风声。他们做的第一件事就是召集一群人来调查此事。所以你几乎得把它当作一个政府委员会来看待。你必须与这些人会面。你必须做笔记。你必须把医疗记录考虑在内。从这个意义上说，它是法医性质的。
You're trying to investigate. Well, what are the facts? Tell us the facts before we start interpreting them. I mean, this almost sounds like a TV show. So, like, who is part of this investigative team? This is so exciting. Yeah, you have the Chicago Pope, which could be like a TV show. And now you have Medical Miracles, which is probably another show.
你在试图进行调查。那么，事实是什么？在我们开始解释之前，先告诉我们事实。我的听众，这听起来几乎像是个电视节目。所以，谁是这个调查团队的成员？这太令人兴奋了。对，你有芝加哥教皇，这可以是一档电视节目。现在你又有医疗神迹，这可能是另一档节目。
Absolutely. I bet you if I've turned on Hulu with TLC right now, that show is on there right now. 100%. I guarantee it. But anyway, this investigative team, generally, there's a bishop involved. There's a local team from the church that tries to get firsthand accounts of the event. The church also gets independent doctors to look at medical records, and they basically try to figure out if there's some scientific explanation for what happened. And if the group determines that there's still something that can't quite be explained, then it goes higher up the chain.
绝对的。我敢打赌，如果我现在打开 Hulu 上的 TLC 频道，那个节目现在就在上面播呢。100% 保证。不过不管怎样，这个调查团队通常会有一位主教参与。还有一个来自教会的本地团队，负责获取该事件的第一手目击证词。教会还会请独立的医生来查看医疗记录，他们基本上试图弄清楚所发生的事情是否有某种科学解释。如果调查小组确定仍然有某种无法完全解释的东西，那么它就会上升到更高的层级。
How high up the chain are we talking like goes to the Vatican? It goes to the Vatican, yeah. So the local diocese, they basically put together this dossier that goes to a department in the Vatican called the Dicastery for the causes of saints. And they have an office in the Vatican City. Yeah, there is an office. You know, I mean, it's a physical office, which are people, you know, go to work and drink coffee and, you know, and have lunch. What's the miracle today that we're looking at? Yeah, they do. I mean, it's part of the portfolio. So, Roman, something I should explain here is that the dicastery for the causes of saints is a department that oversees the beatification and canonization process. Do you have any idea what those words are? Yeah, well, that's how you determine if, like, a holy person is actually a saint, right?
我们说的上升到多高的层级？是去梵蒂冈吗？去梵蒂冈，是的。因此，当地教区基本上整理了一份档案，交给了梵蒂冈的一个部门，叫做封圣部（Dicastery for the Causes of saints）。他们在梵蒂冈城有办公室。是的，确实有办公室。你知道的，我的意思是，这是一个实体办公室，人们去那里上班、喝咖啡、吃午餐。我们今天研究的神迹是什么？是的，他们会的。我的意思是，这是他们工作职责的一部分。所以，罗曼，我在这里需要解释的一点是，封圣部是一个负责监督宣福和封圣过程的部门。你知道这些词是什么意思吗？对，好吧，这就是你如何确定一个圣洁的人是否真的是圣人，对吧？
That's right. There is a process to determine who is worthy of sainthood in the Catholic Church. And the reason miracles go through this office is because you need two miracles to become a saint. So it's like, this is like your resume. Like under special skills, it's like started stopped hearts and stuff like that. You need like a couple of miracles on your resume to make it to Sainthood. Exactly. Yeah, exactly.
没、错。天主教会有一套程序来确定谁配得上圣徒的称号。神迹之所以要经过这个办公室审查，是因为你需要有两个神迹才能成为圣人。所以这就像，这就像你的简历。在特殊技能一栏里写着：起搏并让心脏停止等类似技能。你的简历上需要有几个神迹才能跨入圣徒行列。完全正确。是的，完全正确。
And so in the Rhode Island miracle, that 19th century Spanish priest that the doctor prayed to, that priest is now on the path to sainthood. The Rhode Island miracle is involved in the beatification of a Spanish priest whose file was it dormant for, you know, for a long, long, long long time. And then I think somebody got really interested in the case and literally blew the cobwebs off and started doing more investigation. So what's the next step here? Like the case is now in the Vatican's hands and what happens? Right. So in this department at the Vatican, the dicastery for the causes of saints, which I just love saying, they perform basically a whole other investigation to the miracle. They gathered their own eyewitness accounts. They go back through the
所以在罗德岛神迹中，那位医生向其祈祷的 19 世纪西班牙神父，现在正走在封圣的道路上。罗德岛神迹涉及了一位西班牙神父的宣福，而这位神父的档案曾被搁置了，你知道的，很长、很长、很长时间。然后我想有人对这个案子产生了浓厚的兴趣，字面意义上吹掉了上面的蜘蛛网，开始做更多的调查。那么接下来的步骤是什么？案子现在落入梵蒂冈手中了，会发生什么？对。所以在梵蒂冈的这个部门，也就是我特别喜欢念的“封圣部”，他们基本上对这个神迹进行了另一轮全面的调查。他们收集了自己的目击者证言。他们重新审阅了
medical records. And for a long time, there was actually an official role in this office for the devil's advocate. Wait, so is this like the origin of that term, devil's advocate? Yeah, it comes from this one job at the dicastery for the causes of saints. And the role for the devil's advocate was to find arguments against canonization. And one way you could do that is by poking holes in the miracles. Oh, I am so fascinated by this process. That's so interesting. I think the process This is really interesting, too, but it did change in the 1980s. Like, that title isn't really the title anymore. They have a different, more administrative kind of role or whatever.
医疗记录。而且在很长一段时间里，这个办公室里其实有一个官方职位叫“魔鬼辩护人”（devil's advocate）。等等，所以这就是那个术语“魔鬼辩护人”的来源吗？是的，它就来自封圣部的这个职位。魔鬼辩护人的职责是寻找反对封圣的论据。而你可以做到这一点的方法之一，就是在这个神迹中挑毛病。哦，我对这个过程太着迷了。太有趣了。我认为这个过程也非常有趣，但它在 20世纪 80 年代改变了。那个头衔现在已经不再是那个头衔了。他们有一种不同且更具行政性质的职责或者别的什么。
But today, the people who are, like, poking holes in these miracles are mostly the medical experts. And Father Dorian actually knows a few of these people. My impression with them is that they're more likely to weigh on the edge of, you know, declaring something to have natural, purely medical explanation. They are not in the business of creating miracles or declaring miracles. It's not in their interest because they want the process to be as objective and as credible as possible. That is so interesting. It's so fascinating to have all this apparatus around them. And like you said, like these are all full-time jobs.
但今天，那些在这些神迹中挑刺的人主要是医学专家。多利安神父实际上认识其中的一些人。我对他们的印象是，他们更有可能倾向于，你知道的，宣称某事具有自然的、纯粹的医学解释。他们不是在创造神迹或宣布神迹的买卖。这不符合他们的利益，因为他们希望这个过程尽可能客观、尽可能可信。这太有趣了。围绕着这一切有这么一套机构，真是太迷人了。就像你说的，这些都是全职工作。
They go to the office. They do a thing. Like, who is putting this all together? Like, who pays for all this stuff? That is a great question, Roman, because I think getting a miracle through this process, is kind of a miracle in and of itself. So it can cost tens of thousands, if not hundreds of thousands of dollars, to go through the beatification and canonization process.
他们去办公室上班。他们做一件事。是谁把这一切组合在一起的？谁为所有这些买单？这是一个很好的问题，罗曼，因为我认为让一个神迹通过这个程序本身就是一个神迹。经历宣福和封圣的过程可能要花费几万甚至几十万美元。
And, you know, it's in that process that miracles get reviewed. So it's definitely not cheap. And it helps big time if you have a booster or someone with a lot of money who's interested in the cause. And actually, one of the big reasons these causes get stuck in a sort of purgatory is because it's just so expensive to keep these things moving. So what then happens if this miracle makes it through this new round of medical review and then a second investigation?
而且，你知道的，神迹正是在这个过程中受到审查的。所以它绝对不便宜。如果你有一个赞助人或一个非常有钱且对这项事业感兴趣的人，那将会大有帮助。事实上，这些事业之所以陷入某种炼狱状态的一个主要原因，就是因为维持这些事情继续推进的成本太高了。那么，如果这个神迹经受住了新一轮的医学审查和第二轮调查，接下来会发生什么？
Does it become a miracle at that point? So it has one more level to go through. And this is essentially going in front of a bunch of bishops and theologians at the Vatican. And they're determining, hey, is the person on the path to sainthood really a saint? Are we positive that they are worthy of sainthood? This is where you just make sure that they're not like an ex-merger or something. Yes. Oh, my God.
到那个时候它就变成神迹了吗？所以它还有最后一个级别要过。这本质上是要在梵蒂冈的一群主教和神学家面前进行。他们要确定：嘿，走在封圣道路上的人真的是圣人吗？我们百分之百确定他配得上圣徒的称号吗？在这里，你要确保他们不是什么前梅杰（merger）或者别的什么。是的。哦，天哪。
That would be bad. But also part of this process that they're going through is just determining, like, are these miracles good? Are we buttoned up? Are we sure? Because if someone can easily explain away one of these miracles, that's like not a good look for the church. But it's also not a good look for the church to call something a miracle. if it is done by a person who isn't really saint worthy either. So it becomes kind of, it's like you want the miracle to be a miracle.
那可就糟了。但他们正在经历的这个过程的一部分，也是为了确定，比如：这些神迹是好的吗？我们的程序严密吗？我们确定吗？因为如果有人能轻易地驳倒其中一个神迹，那对教会来说不是什么好面子。但如果把一件并不是真正配得上圣徒称号的人所做的事情称为神迹，对教会来说同样不是什么好面子。所以它变成了一种，你希望神迹真的是神迹。
You also want the saint to be saintly. And if the two come together, then they're both kind of verified by each other. Yeah, I think there's a little bit of that going on for sure. But, you know, if it's able to jump through all these hoops, this miracle, it goes up to the Pope. And ultimately, they say, yay or nay. And in this Rhode Island case, and in a lot of cases, this can take. take years, even like decades for all of this to square away. And for me, at least, that's what I find interesting about this process. It just goes a pretty long way to make a miracle
你也希望圣人真的是圣徒。如果两者结合在一起，那么它们就会被彼此所验证。是的，我想这其中确实有一点这方面的因素。但是，你知道的，如果它能闯过所有这些关卡，这个神迹就会呈交给教皇。最终，他们会投赞成票或反对票。在罗德岛这个案子中，以及在许多案例中，这可能需要花费。需要数年甚至数十年的时间才能把所有这些事情最终敲定。至少对我而言，这就是我对这个过程感兴趣的地方。它为让一个神迹
mean something. You know, just because if you can call anything a miracle, then nothing is a miracle. That's right. Like, if you give out too many miracles, then everyone can be a saint, and you don't want that either. I'm no Saint Roman, but yes, that's the logic. Did I have tell you, like, one of my favorite pieces of box pop tape that was ever recorded and put on the radio was when Ratzinger was selected as Pope. And there's this NPR story featuring this young man who's just like losing it for Ratzinger. And he's like over the moon at Ratzinger becoming Pope. And he's like, we have a new Pope. And it's like, it's an awesome new Pope. We have two great popes right after another. Oh, it's awesome. It feels awesome. It's such an awesome pope following an
变得有意义付出了相当大的努力。你知道，如果随便什么事你都能叫作神迹，那神迹就什么也不是了。没错。就像，如果你发放太多神迹，那么每个人都可以成为圣人，你也不希望那样。我可不是圣人罗曼，但是的，这就是逻辑。我有没有跟你讲过，在广播中播放过的我最喜欢的街头采访录音片段之一，就是拉青格（Ratzinger）当选教皇的时候。有一个 NPR 的报道，里面采访了一个年轻人，他当时对拉青格崇拜得简直要疯狂了。他对拉青格成为教皇感到欣喜若狂。他说：“我们有新教皇了。这真是一个了不起的新教皇。我们接连迎来了两位伟大的教皇。”哦，太棒了。感觉棒极了。在
awesome Pope like Pope John Paul the Great. This is a really amazing, two awesome popes right after another. It means that he'll continue with a great work of hope, John Paul. I'm sure he'll continue World Youth Day. And he's just an awesome, holy man. It just cracks me up and it makes me smile. Oh, my God, I love that. This person is happier about this than I've ever been about anything in my entire life.
像若望·保禄大帝（Pope John Paul the Great）这样一位伟大的教皇之后，能迎来这样一位了不起的教皇，这真是太棒了，接连两位伟大的教皇。这意味着他将继承若望·保禄的伟大事业。我确信他会继续举办世界青年日。他真是一个了不起的、神圣的人。这真的让我笑出声，也让我会心一笑。哦，天哪，我太喜欢这个了。这个人对这事的开心程度超过了我这辈子对任何事的开心程度。
And he just makes me happy to hear him. Two hope, two great popes, one after the other. Anyway, well, this was fascinating stuff. I had no idea where all this stuff came from. I love it. Well, happy holidays to you and the family, Jay, and have a brilliant 2026. I appreciate it, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barube, Vivian Lay, and Jason DeLeon. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha.
听到他这么说，我感到很高兴。两位教皇，两位伟大的教皇，一个接一个。不管怎样，这真是太fascinating了。我以前根本不知道所有这些东西是从哪里来的。我太喜欢了。好吧，祝你和家人节日快乐，杰，并祝你 2026 年过得极其精彩。我很感激，罗曼。本周的 99% Invisible 由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）和杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）制作。混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）完成，音乐来自斯旺·雷尔（Swan Real）。事实核查由格雷姆·海沙（Graham Hesha）负责。
Special thanks this week to Emily Labajoff at the Luxor for help on Chris Burubei story. Next week, Kurt Colstead is going to take us beyond the 99% Invisible City. phone episode next week. And then we'll be back with more mini-stories in the new year. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delany Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Loshamidon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon, and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
特别感谢本周卢克索酒店的艾米莉·拉巴霍夫为克里斯·布鲁贝伊的故事提供帮助。下周，库尔特·科尔斯特德将带我们超越《99%隐形城市》。下周将播出电话特辑。然后我们将在新年带回更多迷你故事。凯茜2号是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德拉尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、洛沙米顿、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、塔隆、雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是天狼星XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。
beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有指向该服务器以及99PI每一期往期节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。